ماذا تعتقدون؟ هل نحن عبيد لكم
نفعل أي شيء تقولونه؟
هكذا رد عمران خان رئيس وزراء باكستان،
على طلبات الغرب وأوروبا!! ...
ترامب يعود للواجهة بخطة
لإنهاء الحرب الروسية الأوكرانية!!،
وروسيا تعلن حذف قائمة من الدول
من خانة الأصدقاء...
سباق الوساطات وتكثيف للمفاوضات
بين إسرائيل والغرب من جهة
وإسرائيل وروسيا من جهة أخرى،
والعنصرية تتجلى في المجتمع الغربي
مع نبذها من قلة قليلة هناك، ...
قوات روسيا تتجه نحو هدفها ولا تحيد عنه،
والرئيس الأوكراني يمل من وعود الغرب
ويقترب من مفاوضات روسيا..
ارتفاع جنوني في أسعار النفط
وقارة أوروبا تواجه مصيرها بنفسها...
فكيف سينتهي الحال بالقارة العجوز؟
بينما روسيا تحاول ألا تضر حلفاءها
وتضع شروطا لذلك في مفاوضاتها...
رؤساء ٢٢ بعثة ديبلوماسية وبعثات الاتحاد الأوروبي،
وجهوا رسالة مشتركة لباكستان،
لدعم قرار الأمم المتحدة في إدانة روسيا،
لكن إسلام أباد امتنعت عن التصويت،
عمران خان رئيس وزراء باكستان يقول:
(ماذا تعتقدون؟ هل نحن عبيد لكم
نفعل أي شيء تقولونه؟
أريد أن أسأل سفراء الاتحاد الأوروبي،
هل كتبتم مثل هذه الرسالة إلى الهند؟
نحن لسنا في أي معسكر،
وباكستان ستظل محايدة)...
روسيا تنشر صورا لتدمير مدفع مضاد للطيران
وآليات أوكرانية،
وصورا تظهر آليات أوكرانية مدمرة
في دونيتسك نتيجة المعارك مع القوات الروسية،،
مشاهد لتعرض معهد خاركيف النووي
للفيزياء والتكنولوجيا للقصف..
موسكو تعلن أنها تراقب مدمرتين أمريكيتين
مزودتين بالصواريخ الموجهة تدخلان بحر البلطيق..
بعد سيطرة القوات الروسية على أجزاء كبيرة
في إيربن، تتجه القوات نحو كييف
من الجهتين الشمالية والشرقية،،
العاصمة محاصرة وتنتظر اقتحام الروس لها،،
قال الرئيس الأوكراني، فولوديمير زيلينسكي،
إن لدى كييف “حلا ممكنا”، لمسألة الاعتراف
بشبه جزيرة القرم وجمهوريتي دونيتسك ولوغانسك.
وبسؤاله عن موقفه من شروط روسيا الثلاثة
في المفاوضات،
قال، “نحن مستعدون للحوار وليس الاستسلام،
بخصوص الناتو، “التحالف لا يفضل الأمور
الجدلية ويتجنب المواجهة مع روسيا”.
وصرح الرئيس الأوكراني بأنه فقد الاهتمام
بمسألة انضمام بلاده إلى حلف شمال الأطلسي،
قائلا “أما بالنسبة للناتو، فقد فقدت الاهتمام
بهذه المسألة منذ فترة طويلة بعد أن أدركنا
أن الناتو غير مستعد لقبول أوكرانيا،
فالحلف يخشى التناقضات والمواجهة مع روسيا”.
ضجة واسعة يثيرها الرئيس السابق
للولايات المتحدة الأمريكية دونالد ترامب،
بعدما اقترح خطة عسكرية، لوقف الهجوم الروسي
على الأراضي الأوكرانية،
(ترامب اقترح وضع علم الصين على طائرات
F22 الأمريكية، ثم يتم إرسالها لقصف الجيش الروسي
ليلا، بعدها تعلن واشنطن أن الصين من فعلتها،
وأضاف ترامب بقوله: حينها سيبدأون بقتال
بعضهم بعضا، ونحن نجلس لنشاهد)
وخلال حديثه أيضا كرر ترامب وصفه للناتو،
أنه نمر ورقي، (كل العالم في كفة
ويبدو أن ترامب يعيش في كفة لوحده)!!!،
(الأحداث والتطورات)
الوساطات تتوالى للجمع بين روسيا وأوكرانيا
على طاولة المفاوضات،،،
وهذ المرة عادت تركيا مرة أخرى
لتعرض استضافة روسيا وأوكرانيا
على الطاولة في أنطاليا،،،
ومنذ بدأت الحرب يحاول الرئيس التركي
أردوغان احتواء الأزمة الأوكرانية
ويحاول التوسط بين الطرفين،،،
قيادة إسرائيل أيضا تجري اتصالات
وزيارات مكثفة للوساطة بين طرفي الأزمة،
برلماني إيرلندي: تفرضون العقوبات على بوتين..
مقابل 70 عاماً بدون عقوبات على إسرائيل
لكن العنصرية تستمر في الدول الغربية
وهذه المرة:
برلماني إسباني يرحب باللاجئين الأوكران
ويصف اللاجئين المسلمين بالغزاة...
أعلنت القوات الروسية أنها دمرت أكثر من
٢٣٠٠ موقع عسكري منذ بدء الحرب،
ومن بين تلك الأهداف ٦١ منشأة تم تدميرها
في يوم واحد فقط،
روسيا تسيطر على ٦مدن رئيسية في زابوريجيا
والمعارك تحتدم في محيط كييف،،
دول أوروبا تضاعف إنفاقها العسكري بشكل غير مسبوق
منذ عقود، بسبب الحرب الروسية الأوكرانية..
الرئيس الأوكراني زيلينسكي يقول:
إن بلاده مستعدة للحوار مع روسيا بشأن كيفية
إدارة حياة الناس في مناطق لوغانسك ودونيتسك والقرم.
ويضيف: “أعتقد أن البنود المتعلقة بالأراضي
المحتلة المؤقتة والجمهوريات غير المعترف بها
إلا من قبل روسيا، يمكننا مناقشتها وإيجاد حل
وسط بشأن كيفية عيش هذه الأراضي.
المهم بالنسبة لي هو كيف ستعيش الناس
في هذه الأراضي من الذين يريدون أن يكونوا
جزءًا من أوكرانيا … السؤال أصعب
من مجرد الاعتراف بهم”.
أعلنت روسيا في بيان مقتضب أنها أدرجت كلا من
الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية والاتحاد الأوروبي
واليابان وكوريا الجنوبية في قائمة الدول غير الصديقة،
لروسيا الاتحادية، كما أدرجت روسيا أيضا
كندا ونيوزلندا وسنغافورة وتايوان والنرويج
وبريطانيا بقائمة الدول غير الصديقة كذلك،
وبحسب البيان فإن الصفقات مع الشركات
والأفراد من البلدان غير الصديقة يجب الموافقة عليها
من الحكومة،،
زيلينسكي مخطابا بايدن والشعب الأمريكي..
( أنا متأكد من أن الرئيس بإمكانه فعل أكثر من ذلك،
ادعمونا! ادعمونا ليس بالكلمات فقط،
بل بخطوات ملموسة ومباشرة،
افعلوها وأعتقد أننا سنفوز
بالطبع إلى جانب العالم بأسره)
تقارير، واشنطن سلحت كييف
ب١٧ ألف مضاد للدبابات في ٦ أيام..
قائمة الشروط التي وضعتها روسيا
لوقف الحرب في أوكرانيا في لحظة،
.. يتعين على أوكرانيا تعديل دستورها،
والتخلي عن المطالبات بالانضمام إلى أي تكتل.
.. اعتراف كييف بشبه جزيرة القرم على أنها
أرض روسية،،
الاعتراف باستقلال دونيتسك ولوغانسك،
يقول الناطق باسم الكرملين ديمتري بيسكوف
أن كييف تعرف ما هي الشروط ،
وأنها يمكن أن توقف الحرب في لحظة...
أعلنت المخابرات العسكرية الأوكرانية
إنشاء وحدة خاصة مما يدعى الفيلق الدولي،
بوزارة الدفاع الأوكرانية وأشارت بأن هذه الوحدات
الخاصة بدأت بالفعل بمهام قتالية لمواجهة
ما أسمته بالعدوان الروسي على البلاد..
قطاع النفط يشهد تقلبات وعدم استقرار
على وقع العمليات العسكرية الروسية في أوكرانيا...
حيث ارتفع النفط  إلى أعلى مستوياته
من عام ٢٠٠٨، حيث وصل سعر البرميل
إلى ١٣٩ دولارا وذلك قبل تراجعه
إلى ١٣٠دولار،
روسيا طلبت من أمريكا تقديم ضمانات لموسكو
بأن العقوبات الغربية لن تضر بتجارتها مع طهران،..
وكانت أمريكا قد أعلنت أنها تبحث مع الأوروبيين
حظر واردات النفط الروسية
وقادة أوروبا يبدون قلقهم على مستقبل القارة
العجوز في ظل الحرب الدائرة بأوكرانيا..
نعم على أوروبا والغرب أن يقلقوا على أوطانهم
فالمارد الروسي قد خرج من قمقمه،
وهو في طريقه لاستعادة أمجاده السوفياتية..
لكن ما الذي ستفعله أمريكا بعد الوصول
إلى هذا الوضع تحديدا؟
...